T
BEING TRANSPARENT, THE NUMBERS
ARE FASCINATING WILLIAM STANDBY
IF YOU WOULD LET'S GET MORE
PERSPECTIVE AND BRING IN THE
FOUNDER AT MEDIA RESEARCH CENTER
BRETT.
I JUST HEARD WOMEN SUPPORTING
THEIR REALLY IS STUNNING TO ME
IN THE TWO THINGS THAT I REALLY
PICK OUT OF THEIR WHICH ARE KIND
OF STRIKING AND SHOCKING AT THE
SAME TIME AS A NEWSPAPERS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ENDORSE DEMOCRATS
3-1 OVER REPUBLICANS AND IF YOU
TAKE TEXAS ON THE MIX IT'S 5-1.
>> YEAH, BUT IT DOESN'T SURPRISE
ME THIS LONG HISTORY OF THIS.
THESE NEWSPAPERS ARE SIMPLY NOT
CONNECTING WITH THE VOTERS.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT TWO
DIFFERENT WORLDS.
YOU COULD SAY OKAY,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND YOUR
TIMES OKAY.
SOME OF THE OTHER NEWSPAPERS AT
SOME OF THEM IN RED STATES THAT
ARE PUSHING BLUE CANDIDATES
LOOK.
WE CAN SAY AND IT'S FAIR TO SAY
THIS.
THE EDITORIAL BOARD.
EDITORIAL BOARD HAS THE RIGHT TO
CHOOSE ANYTHING IT WANTS TO.
IT'S NOT A SIGN OF BIAS IT'S AN
EDITORIAL STATE.
IT'S ON A NEW STATEMENT.
LET'S UNDERSTAND THAT THEN.
LET'S UNDERSTAND HOW LEFT-WING
NEWSPAPERS ARE.
THIS IS WHAT THEY BELIEVE IN,
THESE ARE THEIR GOALS.
THE ASPIRATIONAL'S.
SO WHEN YOU READ THAT NEXT TIME
HE READ THE NEWSPAPER UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU'RE NOT GETTING ANYTHING
CLOSE TO OBJECTIVITY.
YOU ARE GETTING THE WORLDVIEW OF
THESE LEFTISTS.
>> IT TO GET FAIR POINT, BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT CALIFORNIA LIKE
WILLIAM SAYS, 59 DEMOCRATS TO
ONE REPUBLICAN.
IT'S MORE THAN JUST A EDITORIAL
BOARD.
THAT IS VAST.
THAT ASSUME THAT YOU LOOK AT
ENDS LIKE WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
AND IS WILLIAM SET HIM UP WITH
US UP 11 PAPER GROUPS ARE SAYING
THEY ARE NOT CAN ENDORSE IT ALL,
THE DAILY NEWS SAID THE
FOLLOWING QUOTING HERE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO COVER THESE RACES,
BUT WE RECOGNIZE THAT PICKING A
CANDIDATE IN THIS ENVIRONMENT
MAY ALIENATE MORE READERS THAN
IT PERSUADES SO SOME ARE KIND OF
BACKING OUT OF GAME ALTOGETHER.
>> WE BE DOING THIS FOR 30
YEARS, WHY ALL OF A SUDDEN ARE
THEY GETTING SOME KIND OF A JOLT
OF MORALITY HERE?
THIS IS BEEN HER SIGNATURE FOR
GENERATIONS.
BY THE WAY, I'M QUESTIONING THAT
ONE A REPUBLICAN IS BEEN
ENDORSE.
HE'S VERY SUSPICIOUS PERSON.
[LAUGHS]
UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN YOU ARE
READING THE NEWSPAPER YOU ARE
READING A PAPER FROM ENTITY THAT
SAYS IT'S GIVING YOU OBJECTIVE
TRUTH WHEN IT IS NOT GIVING
OBJECTIVE TRUTH.
IT'S NOT THE BIAS FOLKS THAT'S
ABUTTING ME SM LINE ABOUT THE
BIAS.
>> SENT THE LIES THEY TELL YOU
IS THAT YOU THEY DON'T TELL YOU
ON A BRING BACK WILLIAM VERY
QUICKLY HOW DO WE GET HERE THE
QUESTION.
>> THERE WAS A TIME AND IMAGINE
THIS TO ME WHEN A LARGE
PUBLISHERS REALLY DECIDED THE
ENDORSEMENT WAS TO BE THE OTHER
THUMB ON THE SCALE RIGHT?
ISN'T SO MUCH THE CASE ANYMORE
WHEN YOU HAVE THE PEOPLE WHO
GRADUATE BECOME EDITORS AND
EDITORIAL WRITERS IN THE CAN
REFLECTS WITH THE NEWS FROM HIS
THINKING.
SO YOU REALLY HAVE TO BE IF
YOU'RE REPUBLICAN LISTEN.
WITH A B IN THE NEWS PAGES ARE
THE EDITORIAL PAGES IS TO BE
VERY TOUGH FOR ME BECAUSE THAT
ATTITUDE IS REFLECTIVE BOTH IN
THE STORIES THEY CHOOSE AND
THOSE THAT DON'T.
>> INTEREST IN BECAUSE YOU LOOK
AT NOT JUST NEWSPAPERS, BUT YOU
LOOK AT OTHER THINGS ONLINE AND
AS WE TALKED ABOUT A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO AND IS EVEN MORE
PREVALENT NOW.
IS NOT JUST NEWSPAPERS IF YOU'RE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE YOU SEE
SOMETHING WRONG, GOOGLE WILL
BURY YOU.
YOUR FINAL THOUGHTS ON THIS?
>> WE JUST CAME UP WITH ANYTHING
TODAY IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
LOOK TO THE TOP TEN CRITICS OF
GOOGLE RUNNING FOR REELECTION
FIVE AND THE SENATE.
MEMBER THE TWO NUMBERS.
92.4% OF ALL SEARCHES ON GOOGLE.
LESS THAN 1% OF PEOPLE GO PAST
THE FIRST STAGE.
IN ALL TEN CASES THE ALGORITHMS
MANIPULATED AGAINST REPUBLICANS
AND 7-10 CASES THE REPUBLICANS
WERE PUSHED OFF AT THE PAGE.
THIS IS A LEGAL CONTRIBUTION BY
GOOGLE TRYING TO AFFECT
ELECTIONS ANYONE RUNNING FOR
OFFICE IF YOU ARE VOTER YOU WANT
INFORMATION, AND 7-10 CASES YOU
COULDN'T FIND THE CANDIDATE IF
THERE WERE REPUBLICAN.
AND 92% OF PEOPLE ARE GOING ON
GOOGLE'S LOOK FOR TH